he's Kurt Warner he's a hall-of-famer
NFL Network analyst former Super Bowl
MVP you can see Kurt Warner every Sunday
on NFL gameday morning at 9:00 Eastern
Kurt thanks for joining us good morning
your reaction when you heard the Giants
were benching Eli Manning good morning I
was disappointed I think like a lot of
people were disappointed and just the
nature of of how it went down and the
season that they had and all the things
that have gone sideways you know I kind
of expected something like this to
happen to to kind of point out Eli and
you know I just feel like sometimes you
make and put the blame on one guy and
that's what this is that they've had so
many things go bad he's out there
competing and then to make the statement
well Eli Manning's still our quarterback
well he's still your quarterback to me
he deserves to start he deserves to
compete he deserves a chance to be out
there with these guys trying to win
every football game and then I would
have no problem if they said well this
thing goes sideways now we're try to
dabble with it these young guys and see
if we feel they can be a backup to Eli
Manning or the next guy when Eli decides
to retire but to kind of put it out
there like this like hey you can start
when we'll save the streak but but know
that you're not going to finish this
game or you're not going to have a
chance to go the full distance with your
guys we're gonna put these other guys in
I just I didn't like the nature of how
they did it and what they said that they
were with it but also if you're looking
at this I think people have a problem
that you're gonna bench Eli and you're
gonna bring in Geno Smith and say that
you know we want to continue to win
games but we want to take inventory of
these other quarterbacks if Davis Webb
was getting the starting nod I think
people would have less of a problem with
this Kurt you agree yeah I agree you
know I think you know a lot of people
are gonna look and say well Gino had his
opportunities we kind of know what Gino
is we don't know what Davis Webb is but
again I think it's the nature of if we
believe if this Webb is the future and
it's not Eli Manning that to me is
different if you say hey we have to move
and play towards the future that's one
thing but to say well Eli's our
quarterback but that to me is the thing
that's a bit I mean if he's
and you're ready to move on then just
say that and put it out there and let it
be what it is and I think a lot of
people at that point might not be happy
with it or might not agree with it but
at least at that point you go okay this
makes sense that we can you know take
these last few games and see what our
future is because Eli's not our future
but they come out and say yeah yeah he's
still our guy and then as you said to
start Gino instead of Davis yeah just a
lot of curious things and sometimes you
just want to just come out and say what
it is and let us know and you respect
people a lot more when they do that as
opposed to you know kind of going around
in circles and everybody trying to
figure out what what are you really
trying to do here
how were you told back in November of
2004 that Eli was going to be the
starter and you lost your job
what a great respect for Tom Coughlin
because of how he told me he brought me
into his office and we sat down and you
know at the time you know we were a
playoff team we were five and four but
we had dropped a couple games and and he
basically just looked me in the eye and
said Kurt we're going to replace your
quarterback and it really has nothing to
do with how you played and you know
we're in a great position now but I feel
like I have to make this move for the
organization and for the future I have
to start the future right now and you
know I'm sorry it's not fair but that's
what I feel like I need to do and for me
I greatly respected him I didn't agree
with it you know you always want to
believe we're the best guy for the job
should have the job at that point but he
was honest with me and said this is a
move for the future and I just feel like
this is the right timing and
unfortunately you're the one that gets
affected by it but you know I just have
to do what I feel is right and I'm left
there with so much respect for the man
because he looked me in the eye and he
didn't make excuses he didn't try to
blame me or you know or say something
that wasn't the truth he just laid it
out there and and we move forward if Tom
Coughlin was still the coach with the
Giants would this have happened I don't
think there's any chance this happens
knowing Tom Coughlin and what he
believes in and the kind of man that he
is I think he would you know even if you
know you look back at the game and say
well Eli wasn't playing at Eli level and
I can agree with that but again you have
to take the big
go well it was because Eli isn't good
enough anymore is it
or is it because of everything else that
went sideways and I just think Tom's you
know just out of respect for the
situation and as a head coach saying
we're gonna go down and we're gonna
compete and I see that this isn't just
about Eli so it will affect the streak
and the effect what he's meant to our
organization when I know there's a lot
of things going on I don't think Tom
would have made that same decision
he's Kurt Warner hall-of-famer NFL
Network analyst you can see him every
Sunday morning NFL game day morning
starting at 9:00 a.m. Eastern Jimmy
Garoppolo finally gets the start in San
Francisco why did it take this long I
think it just took this long because
you're trying to put him in a position
where he's got enough of a handle on
things that he could succeed you have to
look as an organization when you made
this move you knew this was a move for
the long term but you didn't have to
rush it so it didn't look like you
wanted it to look early and so you know
with Beathard playing decent and getting
that first win I think it bought them a
little bit more time for Jimmy to just
get more comfortable with things but
this was inevitable we knew this was
going to happen at some point this year
with the record but some of those
performances I think where they were
competitive or they won a game allowed
them to say ok Jimmy gets another week
so when he gets in there he can be as
comfortable as possible and have success
because that's really what they need
they need everybody to see this was the
right move here's why and it puts Jimmy
in a great situation to succeed from the
get-go if you're Andy Reed do you make a
quarter vacuum change well I mean it's a
tough one I don't make the team I love
Ellen and I think Alex Smith is a really
really good quarterback and better than
most guys in this league you know the it
always comes down to the idea of are we
here to win championships and do we to
believe Alex Smith can win us a
championship and you know the first
whatever five six games of the year
everybody was watching him and going oh
my gosh this this guy is awesome can do
everything you know he can win a
championship with this team and now all
of a sudden we saw word on that a little
bit but that to me is that is the
question
is that that's what we play for and you
know we've had a lot of questions about
Alec Smith and the game manager and all
that stuff and if Andy Reid feels like
he can only take us so far and we
probably won't win a championship with
Alec Smith now you have to consider to
me the next move in the future I don't
believe that I believe Alex would be so
much better than that you're gonna give
it out in their homes right now and for
this season but I just believe that's
the question you have to ask because
alex is a really really good quarterback
a starting quarterback that has done a
lot of great things he has yet to prove
that he can win a championship but not
to me is the only question that you have
Kurt thanks for joining us have a great
weekend that's a Kurt Warner for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]